foreign
[Music]
Thompson and dream Kardashian dance it
out to a Kanye West classic
on Wednesday night Khloe Kardashian
shared these sweet clips of her
four-year-old daughter true and Coco's
brother Rob Kardashian's six-year-old
daughter dream in their PJs we had fun
the two have a cute cousin dance party
set to yay's 2007 track stronger
[Music]
in another clip true moves and grooves
with some loving encouragement from her
mama
yes true
honestly this is the cute wholesome
content we need my favorite part about
being a mom I mean it's so corny but
it's just like no matter how tired you
are whatever you just it's complete
Bliss and we're in luck because it
appears these dance parties are a
nightly tradition for the besties on
Tuesday Chloe shared this clip of the
girls dancing but this time on the
dining room table
there's no reason
[Music]
and while true and dream opted to move
and Shake Kim Kardashian's kiddos were
busy shaking too literally making
milkshakes I don't know what's gonna top
that that's nine-year-old North
supervising her brother and sister
three-year-old Psalm and five-year-old
Chicago in the kitchen
okay a lot
don't do that much that's that's good
Sami okay okay the sweet sibling moment
was shared to Kim and North's joint Tick
Tock account
okay I'm gonna help you I'm gonna help
you I'm gonna help you I'm gonna help
you bye see you later I'll take two
please it's really fun to see from sweet
shakes to sweet babies
[Music]
on Wednesday Kim and Coco's little sis
Kylie Jenner shared that selfie video
swaying and singing with her son air
[Music]
air turned one-year-old earlier this
month and Kylie celebrated with a sweet
Montage of her baby boy's life so far
you'll never know a dear how much I love
you
please don't take my sunshine away and
the makeup Mogul gave fans their first
real look at baby air earlier this month
finally revealing his name I'm excited
about it of course Kai and her on and
off Beau Travis Scott who also share a
five-year-old daughter stormy originally
named their son wolf a choice Kylie said
she made in a rush before leaving the
hospital I liked the name I don't think
anything
I love it I love it I like wolf I just
wasn't him okay so it wasn't against
anything to do with the name it just
wasn't him so he wasn't a wolf but he
isn't air and we can't wait for the day
when he's able to shake on the dance
floor or in the kitchen with his cousins
[Music]